we get it guys we did a hint we killed
the mean bye bye Johnny
bye bye last week I reviewed
Johnny Johnny me and lo and behold I
gave it a zero and they deleted the
video they scared they know they know
they know the brain you don't mess with
me review no one messes with me with you
Papa and PewDiePie are the same person
a lot of new memes this week thank you
finally Elon Musk went on Joe Rogan
podcast and smoked something something
pretty good memes out of that pretty
good meme side of that yes that's that
we don't have time however thank you
though Elon in the polygon article about
Johnny Johnny how long do you think
Johnny Johnny will be a meme Dolan dark
apparently Dolan dark replied to polygon
you don't talk to the enemy you know
dunking schmuck lien chuckling all right
don't make me uh I can finish you off
that easy and well if the other
short-lived memes from 2018 are anything
to go by I would give it another week
tops you're right
Leon creator behind cartoon the lifespan
of memes can be unpredictable at times
most of them make it less than two
months how about two days how about
thanks hey hey it's polygon box media we
want to hear your opinion about news
just don't reply okay pathetic memes are
so cringy it's just it's just it just
hit me what are we doing here are we all
so desperate to just try and fit in just
that we all have to laugh at the same
jokes
everyone's a more obscure they are the
more part of a select group you feel
like you are but in reality he's just an
idiot laughing that's something that
really isn't that funny famous car
[Laughter]
someone spotted Tanner's car everybody
and they turn it just went Tanner's car
Danis car if you're if you invested in
Thanos means for the love of God sell
now ok the bubble has burst officially
what is this how many layers of irony do
we need for this mean please just stop
of course since Diana's car became a
meme it has to trip over to any other
car meme here we have Thanos car in the
movie cars if we have and from hunger
and real poverty beggars car we're set
this car can fit so many thinners in it
hahahahaha this is brilliant but I like
Tanner's car no Santos our firm on your
card
[Music]
oh my god
you know when Adam Sandler is making fun
of you that's how you know you're at the
bottom okay just stop it please for the
love of God stop the fan of means when
did the Marvel movie came out why does
all the things I hate become the most
popular for tonight
Tanner's T series Thanos cat okay just
stop just cuz it's purple does not mean
it's stay on us okay just get that in
your heads giving this meme a three
everybody Tanner's car gets a three
that's three more than it deserves main
review YouTube show moving on then let
me guess you mean that we reviewed last
week has said it sort of took off honey
let me guess your home not your home yes
it is now god damn it oh my god it
amazes me and upsets me at the exact
same time and it leaves me this
conflicted state okay let me guess your
home
[Music]
it was it was beautiful
let me guess home yes oh my god damn it
that was just pissing yeah
let me guess your car yes it is and
here's my Hot Wheel stop let me guess b7
you sunk my battleship hooray I don't
hate this meme I don't
cuz it's it's kind of those memes that
it fills your day you see it and you get
a little life you know it's gonna be
gone soon but you also know it might
just rebound at some point when you
expect that beliefs so keep an eye out
it's already it's already bamboozled me
once in my Bible so you're twice I give
this meme
I mean correction 5 from 3 to 5 from
last week main correction everybody oh
boy we have a lot of memes so let's just
keep going I was gonna go let's just
jump into it and then I did a high-pitch
for no reason it's pretty awkward
[Music]
you regret but oh it keeps going keep
going mom made bet face posted this meme
on 17th of June it's just some kid who's
using this stupid app that lets you bomb
something this is so sad and people
started making some very creative
version of this it says beautiful thing
it's a beautiful thing
No you know anything can become of me if
popcorn chick you know what actually it
makes perfect sense
[Music]
it keeps spreading
I thought we contained it join us
[Music]
[Applause]
have you underestimated
[Music]
I'm sure put a lot of time to editing
memes oh here's the best one this is my
favorite
can we bring back 2012 montages please
it's time
[Music]
I'm gonna categorize this meme under
important Museum worthy save this for my
grandchildren type of meme gather around
the campfire let's say I'll watch this
kind of meme very nice
Adso it's a - I don't know what to tell
you main I don't know what to tell you
it's it's alright it's funny the edits
are better than the mean okay I'm not
discriminating blessed but not least
believe in something even if it means
sacrificing everything I can tell okay
here's the thing this ID campaign by
Nike went viral because either people
got very upset or they thought it was
really cool
it's not Pew News Felix from remember ok
alright I'm gonna try it the thing
that's great about this is that you can
take this text and put it on literally
anyone else's face any controversial
figure or event in history that no one
likes and bam you got yourself a dank
meme baby I feel like they did this on
purpose they know people would get upset
about this mean they know it would be
controversial if they don't care it
doesn't change anything
people aren't burning their Nike shoes
because of this campaign it's not penis
okay alright
hey look it's Titus again X is again
we're leaving something even if it means
sacrificing half half of everything
that's gonna rate that mean and that's
it for me for me review hope you guys
enjoyed I remember smash like
[Music]